this animation is brought to you by the
nucleus medical art library or enmol
where you can download this animation
and thousands of medical images and
videos created by nucleus medical media
to apply for a free 30-day trial click
on the link in the description
if you suffer from severe obesity and
have been unable to lose weight your
doctor may recommend robotic bariatric
surgery
your digestive system or
gastrointestinal tract
includes your mouth
esophagus
stomach
small intestine
and large intestine
your pancreas
liver gallbladder
squirt digestive juices into your small
intestine to help you break down the
food you eat
your doctor may recommend bariatric
surgery if you are unable to lose weight
and keep it off through diet and
exercise alone have a body mass index or
bmi above 40.
have a bmi above 35 and you have a
life-threatening condition such as heart
disease or diabetes
or weigh more than 100 pounds over your
ideal body weight or ibw
bariatric surgery helps you lose weight
by
decreasing the size of your stomach so
that it holds less food and makes you
feel full more quickly
before your procedure an intravenous
line or iv will be started
you may be given antibiotics through the
iv to decrease your chance of infection
you'll be given general anesthesia
a breathing tube will be inserted
through your mouth and down your throat
to help you breathe during the operation
your surgeon will make a small incision
near your belly button
and insert a plastic tube called a port
carbon dioxide gas will be pumped into
your abdomen through this port
the gas will inflate your abdomen giving
your surgeon more room to see and move
the surgical tools
after your abdomen is inflated a
high-definition camera will be inserted
into this port
your surgeon will make additional port
incisions for robotic instruments as
well as for instruments used by
patient-side assistance
an assistant will insert all of the
robotic tools through these ports
unlike standard laparoscopic instruments
these tools can rotate 360 degrees and
have more flexibility than the human
wrist
seated at a special console your surgeon
will operate the robotic arms and the
camera
with joystick like controls and foot
pedals
a computer will translate the exact
movements of your surgeon's fingers into
precise movements of the surgical tools
at the same time a high definition
vision system will provide a magnified
three-dimensional stereoscopic view of
the surgical area
one common robotic bariatric surgical
procedure is a gastric sleeve procedure
in this procedure most of your stomach
will be removed leaving a smaller
sleeve-like tube about the size of a
banana
to create the gastric sleeve your
surgeon will cut and staple your stomach
at the same time
the part of your stomach separated from
the gastric sleeve will be removed
through one of the incisions
the remaining gastric sleeve does not
change where food enters and leaves your
stomach
at the end of your procedure the
incisions will be closed with stitches
staples surgical glue or closure tape
dressings
the incisions will be covered with
sterile dressings
after your procedure your breathing tube
will be removed
and you will be taken to the recovery
area for monitoring
you'll be given pain medication as
needed
you may continue to receive antibiotics
through your iv
most patients are released from the
hospital one to two days after the
procedure